all right what just one more one more
Herschel Walker clip for today it's
totally unrelated to the abortion
Scandal I just want to let you all know
that Herschel Walker has now jumped on
uh uh the electric vehicle tirades I
think is what we're calling them
Marjorie Taylor green has been blasting
electric vehicles while understanding
very little about it uh Trump has been
attacking electric vehicles to some
degree here is Herschel Walker
visibly confused about electric vehicles
what they are how they work and this is
now a theme among Republicans they're
very very angry about something they
don't really understand you know they're
talking about an electric car right
solar panels it's like but right now
solar panels I want to afford grocery I
want to afford eggs and milk you're
talking about me getting solar panels
gonna be a tax credit to buy electric
car that's caused more than my house so
I'm gonna put the solar pan on my roof
for my house on the roof of my car oh
and that's what I'm living here I said
okay let's get down to the true facts
the true fights are
this is not the new normal for right
this this is definitely not I hope that
candidates like Herschel Walker are not
the new normal now oftentimes I'll look
online at different you know uh
discussions
um about electric vehicles and
um the exact same stuff that Herschel
Walker is saying here it's all confused
it's gobbledygook it doesn't make any
sense it's the same stuff that many of
the anti-electric vehicle people say in
their online forums they're tapping out
these angry messages furiously
it's the exact same stuff that many of
the anti-electric vehicle people uh
email me about okay it might not hurt
him at all in the polls because a lot of
the people already supporting him
believe all the same stuff that he's
saying oh they want to force these
expensive vehicles on us you've got to
take it Point by point on price the mini
SC electric and the Nissan Leaf are
under thirty thousand dollars the Chevy
bolt and the Mazda mx-30 are just over
thirty thousand dollars as new vehicles
use they are even less you will save on
gas so some of the costs now
is made up for later as you don't have
to pay for the gas that they say is so
overpriced and expensive in terms of the
cars cost more than houses
I'm aware of houses in some parts of the
country
that are like 30 grand I I I I've
recently became aware that there are
thirty thousand dollar houses but
Herschel Walker has a multi-million
dollar mansion and so the electric
vehicles are definitely not more than
his house that's for sure now there are
real problems with electric vehicles to
be solved There's real problems with
internal combustion engine Vehicles as
well we could be working on solving the
problems with electric vehicles rather
than dealing with these very silly and
uninformed attacks well there's not
enough charging stations all right well
Joe Biden's trying to work on that and
just put forward a bunch of money in the
infrastructure Bill to build more
charging stations electric vehicles
don't fix the issue
of just too many individual people
driving around in cars we would be much
better off with maybe uh more work from
home combined with better funding public
transit and you just get cars off the
road great and electric vehicles better
than an internal combustion engine but
it would be better for that person not
to be driving around in an individual
vehicle anyway well but Republicans are
against funding public transit the
material intensity and the waste and the
need for so-called conflict minerals for
electric vehicles and batteries what do
we do with the batteries after their
useful life is over there are real
issues here like with just about
anything that exists uh on our planet
they will improve with time but they
will improve much more quickly If
instead of fighting idiotic statements
about electric vehicles like the ones
we've heard from Herschel Walker and
Marjorie Taylor green and others if we
would actually spend time dealing with
the problems better than internal
combustion engine of course
can it improve even further yes but
these Republicans are actively trying to
sabotage it they really are horrible all
of the clips I've played for you in
these first three segments you can watch
them on our Instagram at davidpackman
show and you can react let me know what
you think about the anti-ev nonsense by
finding me on Twitter at dpacman